good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight 2020 has been a tough
year for a lot of americans but it's
been
especially difficult for the experts who
claim they analyze
data for a living a lot of those people
have been exposed for what they are
frauds take the polling business polling
used to seem like a legitimate job
then came november's election despite
their supposedly sophisticated modeling
pollsters around the country got it
wrong by double digits in race after
race
pretty embarrassing but not as
embarrassing as the performance of our
so-called public health
experts they're supposed to be numbers
people too
they told you that any public protest
against their lockdowns had roughly a
150 percent chance of killing the entire
population
meanwhile they declared looting an arson
totally safe
that's just basic epidemiology they said
okay if you're starting to get the
impression that dishonest people can
easily manipulate data to tell you any
story they want to tell you
you may be onto something consider the
condition of our economy
the numbers out of washington suggest
it's in great shape
stock prices 401ks upscale home sales
have all risen dramatically
try to buy an expensive exercise bike or
a million dollar center console fishing
boat
good luck in many cases they're sold out
there are a lot more billionaires than
there ever have been in this country in
fact as a group
billionaires have increased their wealth
by 30 overall this year
that's by more than a total of a
trillion dollars in a single year
no precedent for that at the same time
the unemployment rate is falling you
hear that a lot
so it's all good as joe biden likes to
say we're building back better
well that's one way to look at it but
look deeper
that is not the whole story america has
a very
different economy from the economy we
used to have
even just last year people at the very
top are thriving
many other americans are withering away
small businesses and restaurants
america's backbone
are on the ropes because of the
coronavirus pandemic
limited foot traffic and lockdowns
translate into 164
000 businesses having to close at one
point since the beginning of the
pandemic
with 60 percent having to close
permanently
tens of thousands of independent
businesses shut down for good
entire sectors of the economy wiped off
the map
that's a lot of people out of work so
where are they
why does the federal government tell us
the unemployment rate is down
well here's the simple answer the
official unemployment numbers out of
washington
don't count unemployed people who have
stopped looking for jobs
and there are a lot of those last month
alone another half
million working age americans who want a
job quit trying to find a job
and that's not surprising there are 10
million fewer jobs available in this
country than there were
in february that's when politicians
decided to destroy countless small
businesses
in the name of slowing the spread as a
result of that according to the labor
department
long-term unemployment has hit record
levels
last month 385 000 more americans
reported being
unemployed for longer than 27 weeks
since september that number has
increased by more than
1.5 million so what is our government's
solution to the disaster they created
well more money from the federal reserve
money printed out of nowhere and backed
by nothing
trillions of new dollars spent to fix a
problem they created and more on the way
soon
now keep in mind this is stimulus money
it's designed to help those hurt by the
lockdowns and in many cases
it did help and it will help but in many
other cases the money has gone to people
with the right political connections
a voter registration non-profit run by
the reverend rafael warnock that's the
left-wing preacher
now running for senate in georgia raked
in 482
thousand dollars in coronavirus bailout
money how did he do that
don't ask a firm that happens to be
co-owned by ilhan omar's husband
got half a million dollars in tax money
planned parenthood hoovered up
80 million dollars more abortions for
everyone
the kennedy center in washington home to
the local opera got 25 million dollars
and then laid off
employees anyway last week we spoke to a
man called dave morris morris owns a
restaurant in the midwest
he could have used some help government
shut down his business and now he's
going under
but unfortunately for dave morris he is
not married to elon omar
he doesn't run abortion mills in black
neighborhoods or invite nancy pelosi to
the opera at the kennedy center
so instead dave morris has been forced
to operate illegally just to survive
here's what he told us i had some hope
when they were talking a 2 trillion
dollar stimulus package to help the
american people and when i look at maybe
120 million families in this country 120
million households
and i figured you know geez i get
everybody maybe 10 000
every household that's a lot of money uh
instead that money went all different
directions it went to campaign donors
special interest groups
maybe a couple of museums and it didn't
get where it was supposed to go i never
got any of it
and the small business owners like me
never got any of it that's our money
that's our money well it is but here's
the good news pretty soon it won't be
worth much
the truth is you can't keep printing
trillions of dollars without getting
serious inflation
serious inflation is guaranteed it's
natural law there's no getting around it
the people making these decisions know
that perfectly well
but they want inflation that's the
secret they
want inflation in fact they need
inflation why
because they've gotten rich from debt
that's the real economy
leverage is their entire business model
so for the finance class inflation is
the only way out of all that debt
when money is worth less you owe less
meanwhile hard assets like upscale real
estate and martha's vineyard
will be worth more so inflation may
crush you but it'll make these people
the ones making the decisions
richer everyone else will get the shaft
who's everyone else
well regular wage earners people living
on fixed income
every middle-class retiree in the
country in fact anyone who bothered to
live like a responsible person and save
money
all of them will be in serious trouble
when inflation arrives
that's not speculation it's coming
and anyone who's paying attention knows
it's coming oh but it's just the
beginning
if democrats retake the senate in
january they have committed to passing
something called the heroes act
so who are these heroes they plan to
help
not the thousands of small business
owners whose lives they destroyed
no instead the law will help rich people
in the northeast who were hurt by the
trump administration's last
tax bill the heroes act would restore
the full state and local tax deduction
reversing
the 2017 law that capped it at 10 grand
according to brookings institution 96 of
the benefits from this would go to the
top
quintile of earners 57 would benefit the
top 1 percent 25
percent would benefit the top 0.0
0.1 in other words it would benefit
democratic voters more for the
democratic base that's what this is and
it won't stop there
in october the top democrat in the u.s
senate chuck schumer
announced his support for this idea
we believe that president biden if he
becomes president
could eliminate student student loan
debt without
congress with the flick of the pen that
he has in power so we're proposing that
the first fifty thousand dollars
of everyone's student net will be
automatically eliminated
so student debt is a huge problem the
lack of benefit from
going to a four-year college is an even
bigger problem
we pointed that out many times on this
show but consider
this idea who was helped by what chuck
schumer just said
well it's great news for people who got
pointless master's degrees in gender
oppression
their slate will be wiped clean by chuck
schumer and the magic of the federal
reserve
they'll be free to move forward on that
coveted phd and
transgender equity studies but what
about everyone else
what about small business owners who
spent say 50 grand trying to keep their
employees on payroll
over the past nine months will chuck
schumer wipe their debt clean
how about people with car loans or
burdensome mortgages
or anyone who's helping to pay for their
daughter's wedding what about their debt
sorry they're out of luck unlike the
education establishment
people like that are not big democratic
donors
according to one analysis writing off
student debt in the way that schumer
proposes
would disproportionately help the most
privileged in america
i.e democratic voters but you already
knew that
here's another idea why not make the
people who benefited the most
from the lockdown the people who've
encouraged them from day one pay for the
effects of those lockdowns
why wouldn't you assess i don't know
amazon and apple and goldman sachs and
google and netflix and walmart all the
big winners in this pandemic
why wouldn't you assess them a one-time
covid fee
take it out of their record profits and
make them pay for the next bailout
why are you paying for it jeff bezos for
example is now the richest man
in the history of the world maybe he
could share the load in a meaningful way
he's not sharing with his employees
and while we're at it why not make
harvard and yale and stanford and
princeton
use their endowments to pay off some of
the student debt they caused
there's no reason ordinary taxpayers
should be on the hook for their spending
ordinary taxpayers have suffered enough
here's the bottom line the rich are
getting richer everyone else
is getting poorer that's not a talking
point it's
true and measurable why is it a problem
because if it continues we're going to
wind up with an even more volatile
society
in which everybody hates each other and
is consumed by envy
and along the way capitalism itself will
be discredited and you don't want that
it's already happening
there already an awful lot of socialists
around these days have you noticed that
why is that well it's because the people
in charge of our economy
are discrediting our system they are
giving capitalism
a bad name because what they're
participating in
is not a market economy a free open
market economy it's a closed game
run for their own benefit and their
benefit alone
long term this is a disaster for all of
us
and not even so far in the future in
four years for example
sandy cortez will be eligible to run for
president
now you may laugh at sandy cortez and
you should
she's a vacuous idiot another rich girl
narcissist with an overheated twitter
account
but that doesn't mean she couldn't win
if we keep up with this
nonsense this economic craziness she
could win